speaking of casinos and all that yeah
i invested for you i did some i did some
things
you invested in
airbnb we were talking about here i
bought you with some nfts oh no let me
let me explain the old man trying to
stick his beak in some nfts i bought you
daddy's dry beak i bought you some no
fun toads i might give you some too what
is it i might give everybody some
well they can't butter
well
no fun toads so no fun so this is the
genesis of it when i went to france my
buddy came to join me my buddy mark and
he goes do you think about mnfts no he
goes well
you know there are these images that you
can trade they're like trading cards on
the digital trading card and he goes i
bought an ape because i was asking him
you told us
he bought an eight
go to um
go to [ __ ]
nft apes go ahead he bought an ape now
when they release these apes
they were 250 dollars they were in eath
you buy them oh they're like um
what is it called ethereum yeah there
you go that's it yeah he bought one just
one and you just have the image on your
phone right is that what you said yeah
that's all now now uh it's yours now
what do you do you just put on your
phone now his ape and i i remember he
bought it and he bought it at the time
for like six grand and i was just like
you know these used to be free they were
uh the first one of the first nfts on
the platform and so a lot of people had
like hundreds of those oh yeah now hold
on so let me let me show so so i i
remember i go six thousand dollars i was
like i looked at him like this i was
like well you're crazy yeah well there
are a hundred and the cheapest one is
140 000 right now the cheapest one so
his aid now is worth something like 200
grand now the original ape called board
ape yacht club has
542 million in lifetime sales thank you
280 700 traders yeah please and please
hold then there's cool cats and there's
crypto pumps one piece sold for 69
million dollars is this like the
stylings of like trading cards hold on
so so just please so then there's crypto
punks which the cheapest one is 393
crypto punks crypto punks it's a [ __ ]
weird thing 393 000 hold on it's a it
they trade them back and forth
and they gave those out i believe for
free initially okay now then they went
came up with cryptos cryptos right now
yeah right now cryptos are 60 grand
that's what you bought him so the guy i
know i know a guy
who's launching no fun toads with some
real people yes like some you know now i
don't know anything about this
it's ridiculous i just want to make some
money holy [ __ ] but 1.6 million well
there you go for that that top can you
print it out and put on your wall dude
it's is that an old man question i don't
know
i don't know what to do but i don't
really know i have it
here because i'm not happy i'm not gonna
trust you um here's what happened with
brian that's my agent sorry guys
sorry so this is what happened with uh
with good old bri yeah uh so i i know
some people and they're launching no fun
toads on tuesday well tomorrow
i i took the liberty and you have to pay
me for my price
pay the original price yeah how much do
you pay for them well they're right now
i think they go for about 140 bucks a
total how many did you buy now daddy may
have had daddy may have gotten in on the
ground floor and by the way i'm not
telling anybody by [ __ ] toads
no
i just i've never done i've never
invested you saw how much i'm very
conservative yeah you saw how much
pressure i just think this i know some
people that are really balls deep in it
and they said buy tokyo you'll go broke
if you're like me and you just decide to
go into it that's about it i'm hitching
onto people you only put 140 bucks in
i'm i'm hitching onto people that know
how to do you bought more than one toe
oh i bought us
i got i got some i got
i got some toast i got a big chunk
no fun toads go to go to no fun tone i
wanna go to cryptoads and then go to no
fun toad
go to cryptosphere.com
what's your first product sounds like
you just lost seven ideas adam
sounds like the name of a band no fun
toad kryptonite
band name right no
as they were explaining this [ __ ] to me
i was like dude there's a marketplace
out there that i know nothing about the
difference between ethereum and crypto
uh and and uh bitcoin is so weird i
don't know any of this stuff
and
the whole open season with your dipping
seeds but you're dipping your toad in it
i just think we may as well
like that brian yeah open seas is the
marketplace nope i think it's open seas
bubba opens yeah like the sea yeah open
seas
there it is dot com yeah
and that's where you can buy
no i don't think it's not coming oh cool
that's a [ __ ] uh yeah
what are you doing
there's a marketplace where they buy all
this stuff i have no idea yeah you don't
know the website there he goes there it
goes
oh there it is
[Music]
i was like maybe
i don't think we're the first look at
how much those go those are 60 grand
those are crypto just that yeah and what
are we going to do with that is watching
we're launching we're launching it looks
like oh geez nintendo i know we're not i
mean i don't have anything to do with it
but i i'm buying something so we're
going well now we're going to both
owners one of them is that seven grand
for what wait i can't tell what that is
dude that's easy now which one do we
have point four is thirty five hundred
dollars to eat and eat so so four times
thirty five
and you just get that thing yeah
yeah then do you show your friend they
trade them there's a whole market that's
what i'll say it's like so it's like
trading cards it's used as your avatar
so you guys know all about this i don't
know a little bit about it i was okay is
it like trading cards though i knew yeah
isn't stevie trying to get into it oh
yeah stevie has quite a few right now he
is obsessed with his yakuza cat that's
the next big thing yakuza what's that
now oh like it's like a cat
like an asian thugged out cat like the
art's not even nice
how much are those
.79 you can't even see
they're expensive
that that's what they what did they
originally go for
i think the floor price is fairly low
when he got
on the rise well you should share this
is crazy
go to
nofunto.com
no fun toad no fun toads.com toads or
toad
toad i think it really does seem like a
new age like trading card
toad chin i know
[Music]
let's see
no
is it all one word
no fun
here it is that's what i bought us
well he's cute they're cute and they're
all so they so the computer
generates random ones you get random
ones you can't choose yeah and you can't
get you have to
you can't choose them ethereum is so
interesting that way ethereum is like
they're all these computers right and
they're talking to each other
and the computers create an image that
can't be replicated
that's that's how that works you're the
original owner yes it's like an art
piece yeah there's only one so you have
to think how much that so the value of
the dollar is if there's only one
michael jordan rookie card it's like
millions of dollars okay the value of
the dollar is kind of like as it's like
it's it's transfer value so as it's
traded over the
over you know overseas with different
currencies uh uh it's tax revenue gdp
it's all these different factors that
give you the i'm just saying that that's
cutting my hair
it's just so weird though but that but
but that but he bought his balls
i'm not but there's i just think it's
interesting people really know that
there are computers that like people are
yeah people are deciding okay it's worth
something yeah it's all [ __ ] weird
it's insane
if you bought bitcoin in 2013 that's
stupid to say though because if i bought
apple in 90 in 1989 we'd be billionaires
and i'm not it's not my i'm not into
this i don't i'm not in stocks or any of
that stuff i've smarter people that deal
with all that
what if a week i bet eventually i would
need to learn the [ __ ] what if it weaved
now i'm like hey guys i quit i'm a
billionaire
five million dollars hey guys here's a
toad it's worth 500 million dollars if
that happens dude i'm selling all my
toads i'm not sitting on them no yeah
yeah no get rid of it i've not i have no
idea how long it's going to last let's
sell them obviously immediately yeah
if they go we'll still do the show but
it'll probably last a while we're we'll
replace jim with an actual toad
you have to wear a no fun toad costume
if i get a billion dollars yeah i'll do
it a billion that's a lot a million then
a million
500k are you dressed as a toad every day
well the ape guys made 900 million
dollars in eight minutes apparently when
they launched their second phase of them
i don't know i don't know what to say
about this
i have no idea i don't trust you but and
i don't trust that number and i don't
trust what i just don't know anything
that's going on
the whole sounds like a ponzi scheme but
i'm in
i think that nfc not because you can see
the money from it kind of
yeah well you can see it but that only
means people are willing to yeah that's
what the that's the
the value he said his home you got a
hundred grand two hundred grand no yeah
he bought he bought it